[Music]
long as people have been studying
politics intelligently they've been
understanding that one of the problems
in it key in it is that you give some
people power and you don't want them to
abuse it how do you give it and limit it
at the same time this is a question of
particular importance in the American
Revolution where they have of course
thrown off the king extremely powerful
man because he was bad and he was
exceeding his authority and yet they had
fought this war you know against this
powerful King and they needed to
assemble a lot of power to do it
so they actually wanted more powerful
government but they don't want it to
abuse them what I think the wisest of
them thought was that every human use of
power required to be restrained and
directed toward the good as opposed to
self-interest or the bad so one of the
ways they went they went about that was
to make the government purely
representative that means we get to pick
the rulers but we don't rule so we said
in the declaration independence that the
king was suspending the legislature and
wouldn't let them elect another one all
right
elect another one the representatives of
the people are not meaning you see
consent gives rise to representation now
why would that make for a control on the
government because the government
doesn't receive its legitimacy without
the consent of the governed yeah and it
isn't even abstract right government is
a monopoly you know it's if it's if it's
true as we said before that politics is
natural to the human being that they
always live under laws then it arises
from their gift of speech which is the
classical argument and also the founders
argument about government
then there's always going to be
government right and you're gonna be in
the government and it's going to have a
monopoly on force the other hand it
can't really do anything unless you say
it can and that's not the King's idea
the King's idea is you're gonna have to
have Kings it's in the order of nature I
was born to this I'm gonna be the darn
King and you're gonna be the people and
I'm supposed to take care of you and
you're supposed to do what I say and
that's not grounded in the consent of
either one of us we have the station
we're stuck with it once you change that
and you say the government can really
only do what you say it can do that
limits it drastically I mean how does
the government established what's the
first step in the establishment of the
American government breaking away from
the government we were under happened in
the yeah okay that was good happened in
the we have a code it happened in the
what in the so we get the government
right now we've given consent is that
enough what else do we need wait because
we have to keep giving it right you have
to give consent to form the government
but then after that do you need more do
you need to be saying okay on an ongoing
basis because if you do you're gonna
need a Constitution what was hitler's
constitutionally telling believe what I
say or Die yeah yeah actually yeah I
don't expect you kids to read my books
so I can quote them Hitler came to power
in 1933 and Hitler wouldn't take the job
unless Hindenburg and the leaders of the
main political parties would promise to
support an enabling act he called it
that would liberate the government to do
whatever it wanted
Hindenburg was reluctant about this and
and Hitler very clever man offered him
something he says I won't do anything
that affects the powers of the
presidency in other words the one person
who won't
I won't touch as you and so Hindenburg
said okay right
that itself is a kind of violation of
consent right because end of the rule of
law because now they're not going to
live under the same law anymore right
so Hitler's Constitution as Hitler's
will and that'll work if one person gets
to make all the decisions but if a lot
of people are gonna make the decision
you're gonna have to have some form by
which they can indicate authoritative
Lee what they agree to so if you're
gonna involve a lot of people in the
government you're going to have to have
a constitution you're gonna have and you
see why the constitution has to be
different from the things that that is
actually in the law because it
prescribes the process by which the
ordinary laws would be made it can't be
the same as they right so and that is by
the way implied right through the middle
of the deck rights benefits when they
talk about the king messin with the
government all the time in the way that
he was doing you see so consent requires
representation and representation
requires a written way for that to
happen do you see why you'd have to have
a representative form of government if
you were gonna have a big country why is
that I mean if you had a democracy you'd
have to have everyone there there's too
many people yeah I don't know how many
of you been to Washington DC I go often
we have the Kirby Center they're the
people from coming from California would
be at a terrible disadvantage from the
people who live in Northern Virginia
right and so it can't be very big if
it's not gonna be representative is that
there has to be some mechanism for
consent and since they can't all meet
the way they're going to have to elect
some people now now that we know that
consent requires not just agreement that
there's going to be a country but a
mechanism so that people can govern
oversee the actions of the government
over time and now that we see that if
you're going to have a big country
you're going to have to have
representation this opens up a whole
world these two things
the founders it turns out are really
glad that this world that I'm about to
describe we're about to describe happens
Cuffy is open because what do they think
about democracy it fails and why because
the majority ultimately starts to rule
there's no protection of the minority
interests becomes tyrannical you can't
control faction defined faction
Christian any group interests that may
or may not have the majority Emily it's
also on top of that the interest that it
has is in violation of somebody else's
interest within that group or of the of
the whole yeah the public interest in
the very famous Federalists in how do
they describe the public interest
there's an expression they use it's
really great
I think they describe it as the
permanent and aggregate interests of the
community well then yeah the permanent
an aggregate interest of the community
which would be this a separate thing
from the particular or temporary
interest of any one of us or group so
it's not by the way just stopping the
government from doing what it wants to
the governed and remember in a
representative system there's gonna be
something you call the government and
they're going to be different from the
people they represent that's how we
solve the problem that that Lilly
brought up the problem that the people
in California don't have the same chance
to get to the meeting as the people in
Northern Virginia
right you're gonna appoint them to do it
right and so one one thing
representation does is it stops them the
them who are the government from doing
stuff to the government that the
government don't like so if you have a
constitution you can spread the
decisions out over time by having
representation we've already said you
spread the decisions out over space
right you can have a bigger country and
everybody can have a second it because
they'd have to go there all the time you
they can all have the same say in it but
also over time in other words reason
alone of the people must be placed in
control of the government their passions
must be controlled by it rights James
Madison that means by the way do you see
what I just said the implication what I
just said I think on this point that I
know better than many citizens in there
were and and the majority of the
citizens in their worst moments are time
wise right Constitution doesn't let me
change it just because I think so
or just because I've studied it for a
long time government is by nature very
powerful it has a monopoly on power it
has to be like representative government
requires a society separate from the
government big enough to control that
great
you
[Music]